thomas bonjour alors la stratégie de
vaccination critiqué de toutes parts et
on peut imaginer que la journée
s'annonce agitée ici au ministère des
solidarités et de la santé il faut dire
que les premiers jours de cette nouvelle
année 2021 ont été quelque peu compliqué
et c'est un euphémisme que de le dire
puisque en date du 2 janvier dernier
moins de 500 français avaient été
vaccinés c'est nettement moins que
d'autres pays même des pays européens
qui ont pourtant lancé leur campagne de
vaccination à peu près en même temps que
la france en allemagne par exemple on
estime à environ 200 milles
le nombre de citoyens allemands qui ont
pu bénéficier du vaccin alors bon nombre
de professionnels de santé tire à boulet
rouge contre le manque d'organisation en
cause notamment l'absence de centres de
vaccination en france c'est par exemple
ce qui se déroule en ce moment en
allemagne alors l'exécutif justifie
cette lenteur par la stratégie qui a été
mis en place et qui vise dans un premier
temps à cibler les personnes âgées
présentes dans les ehpad ainsi que par
les formalités administratives
nécessaires avant de pouvoir procéder à
la vaccination et du côté du
gouvernement après avoir assumé une
certaine lenteur dans la stratégie
maintenant le discours a complètement
changé thomas
oui emmanuel macron tape du poing sur la
table c'est en tout cas ce que laissent
paraître un article du jdd d'hier c'est
parmi les citations en off du président
de la république qui sont rapportés on
peut notamment lire ce n'est ni à la
hauteur ni du moment ni des français
ou encore ça doit changer vite et fort
et ça va changer vite et fort
alors pour répondre à cette colère
présidentielle
les ministres concernées promettent une
accélération de la campagne de
vaccination avec un calendrier qui est
d'ores et déjà révisé les professionnels
de santé âgés de plus de 50 ans peuvent
désormais être vaccinés à compter de ce
lundi et puis pour sa part le porte
parole du gouvernement promet que le
retard sera rattrapé d'ici la fin du
mois de janvier toujours est il que ce
début d'année 2021 a tout l'air d'un
gros raté pour le gouvernement qui
essuie des critiques de toutes parts
l'opposition soulignant un nouveau
fiasco après celui des masques et celui
des tests autre critique elle porte
cette fois sur une idée pour le moins
originale
à compter de ce lundi 35 citoyens vont
être tirés au sort
leur rôle sera nous dit-on d'accompagner
la campagne vaccinale pas sûr que cette
idée suffisent à faire oublier les
errements du gouvernement merci beaucoup
thomas pour toutes ces précisions thomas
bonnet en direct du ministère de la
santé ce matin